[Music]
today for our daily cancellation i must
once again cancel camila harris
now at this point the bar for kamala
cancellations is pretty high if i
canceled her every time she said
something embarrassing or stupid we'd
never be able to talk about anyone else
during this segment
so she has to really bring the good
stuff in order to earn it
and she really did earn it this time
listen
is agreeing to voter id one of those
compromises that you'd support
i don't think that we should
underestimate what that could mean
because in some people's mind that means
well you're going to have to
um xerox or
photocopy your idea to send it in to
prove you are who you are
well there are a whole lot of people
especially people who live in rural
communities who don't there's no
kinko's there's no office max near them
people have to understand that when
we're talking about voter id laws
be clear about who you have in mind and
what would be required of them to prove
who they are
of course people have to prove who they
are
but not in a way that makes it them it
almost impossible for them to prove who
they are
almost impossible so there she was on bt
giving her thoughts on voter id
credit where it's due she is she is
correct that uh for people in rural
communities there's no kinkos
nearby to photocopy an id that's because
kinkos doesn't exist and has not existed
for like 15 years or something
rural americans are as near to kinkos as
they are to i don't know a heckingers or
an ames department store
and because they don't exist they come
to think of it she's correct about the
rest of what she said also
i just moved from a rural community um
where i lived and the only photocopier
we had was an old amish man named
gabriel who would produce a sketch
using coal and parchment paper in
exchange for a bale of hay in three
years of corn
but old gabe didn't work as fast as he
did in his younger years so it would
take a good six months for you to get
the document sometimes um i didn't even
know that these newfangled photocopiers
existed until i moved to the city in
fact i
i walked into a staples i got here to
nashville and uh is my first time being
you know around buildings and and cars
and everything and
i walked into a staples and uh and i saw
people reproducing images with
these large noisy machines and the first
thing i thought was that it was some
kind of sorcery
especially because it stopped working
the minute i dumped a gallon of holy
water on it
these dang city folk are in league with
the devil i tell you
actually i do unironically believe that
many people in the city are in league
with the devil
but that has nothing to do with their
photocopier technology which contrary to
camille harris's claim
we did have access to out in the country
in fact we had computers and phones not
to mention
electricity and running water
we even had them there fancy things that
kept our food all cold and icy like
refrigerator i think it was called as a
matter of fact
even though i was a simple country boy i
knew
and this is what i did because i was a
little bit far away from the nearest
place to
to to photocopy and uh so so
i knew that i could make photocopies on
my phone anyone can download an app for
free that will scan
any physical document there's a nice
little tip for you if you didn't know
that
really really convenient i also knew
that i could buy a copier and printer if
i wanted to i could go on uh what's the
the internets and go to amazon you could
order one they'll send it to your house
or if need be i could get in my
horse-drawn carriage and make the
journey to fedex or staples
or the post office or any of a dozen
other places that can handle the
complicated task of photocopying an id
whatever method of photocopy you prefer
the good thing is that wherever you live
if you want to participate in a
presidential election
you have four whole years to figure it
out
is there anyone in america who can look
back at the last four years of their
lives
and say that during that entire time
frame they were simply unable to make it
to a staples
even gabriel the amish guy could get it
done in four years
even if the nearest staples was 400
miles away
and i was living out in the wilderness
and i had to walk the whole distance
and yet somehow i had an id in the first
place i could still do it in four years
with time left over time to spare there
is quite literally
no conceivable reason why any single
human being
in the modern united states should be
prevented from voting by voter id laws
and that's probably why people like
camilla harris never provide
any actual examples of any specific
real-life people
who wanted to vote and yet were unable
to vote
because during the course of the
preceding four years they were unable to
get an id
and or make a photocopy of one i contend
that such a person does not exist and
note that if such a person did exist
it still would not prove that voter id
laws are bad or unreasonable or
cumbersome
that the law is cumbersome to a small
minority of extremely incompetent people
is not an argument against the law
itself but the anti-voter id position is
so absurd so lacking in any factual
basis whatsoever
that i doubt that any small minority
exists
they exist only in the imaginations of
infantilizing politicians like camila
harris
who think that rural americans exist in
some kind of 18th century
time warp or at least they pretend to
think that
as fun as it is to mock this sort of
thing
we can't make the mistake of believing
that camilla harris actually believes it
if she did then she would be stupid and
sheltered and ignorant in the extreme
but still basically well-meaning
she's not well me meaning she knows they
all know
that any adult human in the country can
easily qualify to vote even under the
most stringent voter id laws
currently being enacted or proposed
all these laws will do is confirm that
the people voting are who they say they
are
just as you have to prove that you are
who you say you are in order to do
almost anything else in adult life
from buying alcohol to renting a car to
staying at a hotel to procuring an
apartment or a home etc
the people who oppose the laws then
oppose them because they want the
process of voting to be far
less secure than the process of buying a
six-pack
of heineken at the gas station
and why is that because they want
voter fraud there is no other reason to
take the position
that they've taken that is pretty clear
and for that reason camilla harris
is cancelled listen hit that subscribe
button
right now do it right now i thank you
for your compliance
it is somewhat appreciated